نداء عبر اللاسلكي،
1-1
الهدف موقعي
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمد سوالله الله
اطلق اطلق ..انتهى
وهنا كانت نهاية بطل عربي،
جعل من نفسه وقودا لينير درب العرب
( لتتابعوا ما الذي حصل عندها، للقصة بقية)
كان الشهيد خضر شكري يعقوب،
أول من استخدم الكمي كاز اليابانية على طريقته الخاصة
عندما جعل من نفسه لغما بشريا، في بطولة فاقت الوصف،
وفداء ليس كمثله فداء،
للغوص في تفاصيل قصة الشهيد يعقوب أكثر،  فقد بدأت معركة الكرامة
بعد عام واحد على خسارة العرب في نكسة ٦٧
و كانت مهمة البطل هي مراقبة تحركات العدو لتمرير مواقعه للقوات الأردنية لرميها.
ولدقته المتناهية برصد مواقعه في معركة الكرامة وتمريرها
ومن ثم قصفها من قبل الجيش العربي،
ارتأت قوات العدو أنه لابد من التخلص منه، فكشفوا موقعه،
وتم تطويق "التلة" التي اتخذها مركزا له.
ضيقوا عليه الخناق، وكان برفقته جنديان،
فاشتبك ثلاثتهم بالأسلحة الفردية مع قوات العدو حتى نفدت ذخيرتهم.
لم يبقى لديهم سوى وقت قصير،
أراد شكري أن يستغله  بحث  رفاقه على الشهادة في سبيل الله والوطن
ورفض تسليم أنفسهم وما يملكونه من معلومات عسكرية للعدو الصهيوني.
وكان هدفهم تخليص الأرواح، عبر عملية استشهادية نبيلة.
وفي حين وصل إليهم العدو، وكانوا أكثر من فصيل،
أتلفوا كل ما لديهم من أجهزة وخرائط وما يلزم لعملهم كضباط ملاحظة.
ولم يبقي لدى شكري ورفاقه سوى جهاز واحد مرّر من خلاله
مكانه للقوات الأردنية كهدف.
حاصره العدو أكثر فأكثر، حتى وصلوا إليه تماما،
فأوعز لكتيبة المدفعية برمي الموقع قائلا:
"موقعي محاصر، اقصفوه حالا".
(نداء الى المدفعية .. نداء الى المدفعية
الهدف موقعي اقصف الآن،
ونطق الشهادة، وجعل من قنبلة بشرية فتيله بيد قوات المدفعية،
وراح ضحيتها العشرات من أفضل جنود العدو الصهيوني
تلك الضربة التي أسهمت بتحقيق النصر المؤزر للجيش العربي
على العدو الصهيوني في موقعة الكرامة،،،
تسمى عسكريا بـ"هدف تخليص الأرواح"
كانت الأولى من نوعها في تاريخ الحروب العالمية،
عندما علم خضر شكري أن نهايته قد حانت وأن العدو سيقضي، عليه،
قرر أن يرحل ويضحي بنفسه لكن ليس وحده
بل مع أعدائه الذين حاصروه ووصلوا إليه،
فطلب أن يسوى بالأرض لكن مع عدوه،
فالبطولة ليست في المعركة فقط،
بل بكيفية الرحيل.. وهكذا يرحل الأبطال.،،